all right so today we are going to uh
play another video game and i'm going to
offer another one of my
my patented video game reviews all the
whole gaming community now is looking to
me as sort of their guide and their sage
uh what do we play this is grand theft
auto correct this is grand theft auto 5.
okay grand theft auto 5 and this is one
of the latest and greatest newest games
is it not uh no it's actually pretty old
i think over five years old
[Music]
now so why we because i i thought i
wanted to connect with the kids and play
the most recent game is this a popular
game that kids still play
yeah it's been out for a while and it's
remained popular since it came out five
years old my grandfather probably plays
this if he was not dead all right so
what okay what's the point of this game
i'm just gonna i'm uh well there i am
and i've got my my polka dot shirt and
i've got the skinny pants on so
i've got the beers that really does look
a lot like me glasses wow
now i feel a certain kind of connection
and like ethical responsibility here
because i do feel like this person is in
some ways
me so what's the what's what am i doing
jacob uh you're just walking around that
you're in los angeles right now and
you're just doing every whatever you
like
okay
well it's a nice evening so we'll just
uh we'll just go for a walk you have a
truck behind you if you want to drive
somewhere yeah no i thought i'd just
walk
i'm just walking along
[Music]
you know i kind of like this i don't
really see the point because i feel like
i could just go outside and walk on the
sidewalk are there any guns do i get any
weapons or anything
yeah push the
upper right button on the top of the
controller
oh
there we go
all right
i'm not looking for any trouble i'm just
going for a walk how do i aim and shoot
oh why oh
sorry i didn't mean to do that
was that a bad guy or just a random
civilian i just shot for no reason that
was a guy just strolling like you
well
he looked like he was up to no good
frankly
i don't know who the bad guys are so i
just have to shoot everyone it feels
like
you're the bad guy
is there a
you know a point is there sort of a
purpose is there a thing that i'm
supposed to be doing
yeah uh go up to a car and push triangle
okay
here we go
oh what
this isn't even my car
all right
all right okay
so how do i how do i steer so that i
don't look drunk
use the right stick to steer
how do i is this okay can i just say so
can we stop for a second oh oh sorry
about oh my goodness
well
a bounty has been set on me what does
that mean
i was just going for a walk i was fine
just walking along and now i'm wanted
for murder
red light
i mean i think it's this is one thing my
dad taught me when i was a you know
young driver is it's all good driving
kids is all about is all about good
habits and so he would say you know even
there's nobody behind you still hit the
turn signal because it's all about
forming those good habits and i think
even in video games it's important to
just develop those good habits
yeah i gotta say i don't feel great
about killing that guy i know it's just
a video game but
but at the same time i also feel great
about it and that's the thing that
concerns me the most i feel sick to my
stomach but i kind of enjoyed it
how much do the traffic laws matter in
this game
if you violate them you'll get shot
are those cops coming for me
yeah they are you better get out of
there
it was a misunderstanding officer
okay can i get out of this car and pick
a new one yeah push triangle
oh
what
who just shot me the cops yeah it was
the police
i was getting out of the car i was
clearly about to surrender uh i i shared
last time we did this we played call of
duty and i said you know i hadn't played
a video game since super mario world
super nintendo back in elementary school
although it did occur to me after we
shot that video like recently last
couple days i had this flashback moment
where i remembered i in fact did own
another video game system and i believe
it was called dreamcast
and my parents got it from a flea market
and uh gave it to me for christmas and
that's when i really knew that they
didn't love me and so that actually was
if i'm not dreaming and hallucinating
this entire thing that actually is my
last experience with video games i don't
like this game i got to tell you
i don't approve of it i don't like it
i really think it conditions if there's
a certain like moral conditioning that
happens in games like this
okay we're now on a mission there's a
dealership down by davis they're
offering reasonable finance plans what
this is the mission you gave me
to go check on the reasonable finance
plans what kind of
how is that a mission
like bargain hunting is the mission
isn't it like there's a bomb i have to
go defuse it before it kills a truckload
of puppies or something
no the mission is you destroy their cars
everybody
i go kill the puppies is the mission
that's a mission i would actually accept
all right go to the rival dealership
let's get in the car here
just gonna borrow this one okay so i
have to use the gps to find out where
the dealership is
exactly
well how can i look at the yellow line
and look at the road while i'm driving
all right taking it right here
come on
what
well
you're a female driver
what do you expect
okay take a right
we'll get
all right let me get out of
here oh my gosh this is like too
involved just give me sonic the hedgehog
2d
rolling along picking up coins
this doesn't even feel right you know it
it it feels
like morally wrong that i could just
walk up to a person
and just shoot them like that the fact
that i can do that is you know is not
good you should not be allowed to do
look at that you shouldn't be allowed to
do that in the game
as i slaughter civilians with abandon i
object to the fact that i'm doing it
okay how do i take this car
oh i didn't mean it i didn't know there
was somebody in it sorry about that
sorry about that okay
all right i'm just trying to get to the
dealership officers
why are the cops still coming after me
they already killed me i think because
you stole a car oh okay
well that's reasonable sharp right
ah
okay
all right here we go
dealership look at that
mission complete do a barrel roll
probably could have parked the car
before i dive dove out but is that it i
found the dealership that's the mission
right now you have to destroy the cars
that are in the parking lot
destroy
cars good to be a gangster a real
damn
the
gangsta type player plays his cards
right a real gangster type player never
runs his mouth cause real gangster ride
players don't start fights hey who's
that
is it coming from the sky the cops are
behind you
i can't
i don't
that's it i can't do it
i i don't i can't do it
mission failed i'm a failure i think
that's good i think i've gotten a taste
of this game i think i've shown what i
can do i think i've shown my skill level
which is exceptional
i've also shown that when given the
opportunity without any cost to myself i
will go around
mowing down random pedestrians and
killing innocent people which i'm not
happy with myself so that's something i
gotta reflect on but overall i'll give
this game
[Music]
eight stars out of ten damn it feels
good
if you didn't like that content then you
probably have
discerning taste but still
if you want to see more of that and much
more uh than than just me playing video
games make sure to hit like and
subscribe right now do it now